Let me just briefly recap.
As we're moving into the literary profits or the classical prophets are
sometimes called,
it's easiest to think of them as being associated with particular crises in the
nation's history.
We're not going to be looking at them all,
and I've picked out some of the main ones that we'll be looking at.
Really,
they're exemplary in a number of different ways.
So you have profits of the Assyrian crisis.
This is when the two kingdoms still exist.
So in the north prophesied in Israel you have Amos and Hosea,
and in the south of Isaiah and Micah,
they'll so think of those four books together.
It'd be easier to know what the differences among them,
if you group them together and we'll be doing that.
Then the profits of the Babylonian crisis.
By this time the northern kingdom has fallen.
We're moving towards the end of the seventh century.
The Assyrian Empire has fallen in six 12 the profit knock home talks about the
fall of Assyria and we move then into the very end of the century and down to
the beginning of the sixth century with the destruction of,
of Judah.
So profits associated with that time,
particularly Jeremiah,
uh,
on also also have a cook.
Then we have the profit of the exile who is Ezekiel and then the post exhilarate
period or the restoration when the,
when the Israelites were allowed to return to their land.
And we have several profits at that time.
Hi Guys,
Zechariah,
Joel and Malakai.
We're B will be,
the profits will be looking at briefly.
There are three long prophetic works and I have circled those,
Isaiah,
Jeremiah and Ezekiel one associated with each of the three crises.
So again,
another mnemonic for you is to sort of think of them,
um,
each associated with each of those major crises.
Um,
and the rest are all much shorter works.
I think Ovadia value being the shortest,
really just a very,
very short work.
There's been a long debate over the degree to which these classical or literary
profits we're harking back to longstanding Israelite traditions or constructing
norms that would later come to be viewed as longstanding Israelite traditions.
Uh,
Koufman describes these classical profits as the standard bearers of the
covenant.
This is his term.
And in his view,
they couldn't be seen as conservatives.
But by the same token,
he says the new prophecy conceived ideas,
um,
that,
that Israelite thought of the earlier time had not conceived.
And in this sense,
Koufman argues they are also radical.
He describes them as radical conservatives are conservative radicals.
Um,
as a result of the radical nature of some of their mesh message,
the profits had to speak with great exaggeration.
And you will notice this when you read the writing,
great exaggeration,
a lot of dramatic imagery,
um,
dramatic features.
They denounced the people,
they chest dies,
the people,
uh,
and as a result they were often scoffed at or even persecuted in return.
But eventually the nation would come to enshrine their words.
And it's ancient sacred heritage,
which is testimony to the fact that their message must have served a crucial
role at sometime in the changing political and religious reality.
Now we've already talked about the Deuteronomistic historiography and how it
developed as an interpretation of the historical catastrophes of seven 22 and
five 86.
And this interpretation made it possible for Israelites to accept the reality of
the defeat of the nation,
that feed of Israel without at the same time losing faith in God,
the defeat of Israel,
the exile of the nation was not to be taken as evidence that God was not the one
supreme lord of history or that God was a faithless God who had abandoned his
covenant and his people.
The defeat and the exile were interpreted to affirm precisely the opposite God
as the universal God could use other nations as his tool.
He could use these nations to execute judgment on his people,
and he did this in an act of faithfulness,
ultimately faithful to his covenant which promised punishment and chastisement
for the sins of the people,
the sins of idolatry,
the classical literary prophets,
Isaiah,
Jeremiah,
Ezekiel,
and the 12 minor prophets follow the basic thrust of this interpretation of
events.
They agree that the defeat and the exile are evidence rather than disproof of
God's universal sovereignty,
and they agree that they are gods just punishment for sin,
but they're going to differ from the deuteronomist in two significant ways.
First they're going to differ in their identification of that sin for the
profits.
It isn't just idolatry,
uh,
for which Israel is punished,
although that's important too.
And second of all,
they're going to differ in their emphasis on a future restoration and a glory,
a message that we don't find in the Deuteronomistic historian.
The individual books of the prophets are really arranged according to two
principals interacting principles,
size and chronology.
So you have the first three books are the very large prophetic books,
Isaiah,
Jeremiah and Ezekiel,
Ezekiel in chronological order of the three crises we've outlined here.
Uh,
and then you have the minor prophets and the minor prophets again are in roughly
chronological order.
Um,
although book size also plays a bit of a role in arranging these materials.
And I was very common in the ancient world,
first for size to determine the order of books and a corpus.
Um,
we are not going to be following the order of the cannon,
um,
because it does jump around chronologically first with the large three large
books and then going back and having some of the smaller books of earlier
profits.
We're going to be looking at them in in chronological order.
We're going to be looking at them against the backdrop of the historical crisis
to which they're responding.
So we're going to begin with the first of the literary profits,
even though it's not the first in the order of the,
of the Bible.
And that is Amos and Amos preached during a relatively stable period of time.
This was in the northern kingdom,
is around seven 50 under the reign of Jeroboam.
The second,
not the first,
and this is at a time before the Assyrian threat is,
is becoming very apparent and,
and,
and a series empire building ambitions before those are becoming very apparent.
There are many passages that suggest that Amos was an ordinary shepherd.
He came from a small town about 10 miles south of Jerusalem.
So he came from the southern kingdom to prophesied in the northern kingdom.
He was called to Bethel,
which was one of the royals sanctuaries in the northern kingdom to deliver his
profits,
his prophecies.
Um,
but despite the suggestion that he was an ordinary shepherd,
it seems more likely that he was probably a fairly wealthy owner of land and
flocks.
He was probably educated and literate.
Um,
the northerners are said to be very surprised by his,
his eloquence and his intelligence,
but they didn't like his message.
And ultimately he's going to be forced to go back to the southern kingdom.
The book of almost can be divided structurally into four sections,
which I've listed on the board over here.
You first have a set of,
of brief oracles of doom is there in the first two chapters.
I'm a one and two.
And then you have a series of three short Oracle's Oracle's to the women of
Symeria and Oracle to the wealthy,
have some area and Jerusalem and then an oracle to Israel as a whole.
These are in chapters three through six.
This is followed then by five symbolic visions which receive interpretation.
These are visions of judgment first locusts than a fire,
than a plumb line that one uses.
And building a building,
um,
a basket of fruit and then a vision of God standing by the altar at Basal.
This happens chapters seven through nine,
um,
about verse eight and nine.
It also,
this section besides the five visions also has a little narrative account of
emesis conflict with a priest at Bethel,
the priest Matsiya who accuses most of treason.
All right.
And then there's a concluding epilogue in the ninth chapter that runs for about
seven or eight versus to the end of the book.
So the book of Amos is a wonderful place to start for us because it contains
many features that are going to be typical of all of the classical profits,
all of the literary profits by and large.
And also this book introduces certain major themes.
These will become standard themes of prophecy with some variation here and
there.
So by setting them out in the book of Amos,
then we can really go forward and just look at the variations on some of those
themes that are sounded by some of the,
the other profits.
So first some literary features.
And then we'll talk about the themes of the book.
In terms of literary features.
I've jotted down a few here.
You see in the book what we would call editorial notes.
That is to say,
um,
you have notes in the book of Amos,
which are in the third person.
These won't very often occur at the beginning of a book.
They sort of introduce her,
set the stage.
So we have an Amos,
the words of Amos,
a sheep,
a sheep breeder from Tacoma who prophesied concerning Israel in the reigns of
King's Uccja of Judah and Jeroboam,
the son of Joe,
wash of Israel two years before the earthquake.
So almost all of the prophetic books are going to contain an interdict
introduction of this type,
some third person,
um,
phrase which will identify the place and the Prophet and his time.
Um,
there's another kind of,
um,
uh,
of writing in some of these works as well.
Um,
which is in the first person.
It's not always in the third person,
but you sometimes have first person passages in which the prophet himself,
we'll speak about and describe something about himself.
Right?
It's,
it's stepping aside from the irregular moment and,
and speaking in some way about some experience that he's had.
So we have these first person and the third person passages that give us
information about the profit.
The third person passages we surmise may have been written by the prophet,
but they were probably written by disciples or others who were responsible for
collecting the profits.
Oracles,
indicting the profits.
um,
almost seven is an example of this.
In almost seven,
we find an example of this kind of writing again where you have a description of
Amos in debate with a priest,
priest dementia at the,
at the shrine of Bethel.
Okay?
So you have the irregular statements,
but you also have these other,
um,
identifying passages as well and descriptive passages.
Um,
this brings us then to a second point,
which is that the prophetic books are a compilation of a variety of materials.
All right?
They consist of varied materials that have been collected.
They've been revised,
they've been supplemented the profits,
Oracle's which were delivered in various situations over a period of time.
We're apparently saved and then compiled again perhaps by the prophet himself,
perhaps by his disciples.
We know that prophetic oracles were written down and transmitted in other
ancient near eastern societies.
We know this about a Syria for example.
These were literary compositions.
And the literary nature of these compositions will account sometimes for their
ordering.
Sometimes,
um,
it appears that there is not chronological ordering.
This is one of the things that can make it so hard to read some of the prophetic
writings because they are not,
the oracles are not necessarily in chronological order,
they are literary works and sometimes the profit or the disciple or the editor
would combine principles or juxtapose,
sorry,
combine oracles or juxtapose Oracle's according to principles other than
chronology literary principles.
So for example,
you very often find the principle of a catchword,
a prophecy or oracle that might end with a particular word in,
in its last line or last spurs.
And so next to it will be a second prophecy or Oracle,
which echoes that word in its opening line.
And so the two have been brought together for literary reasons.
So Amos three verse two reads,
you alone,
have I known of all the families of the earth and that's the concluding line of
that particular oracle.
And that verb to know is probably the catchword for the oracle that follows
because the next one opens.
Do two people walk together unless they know each other.
So that may have suggested the juxtaposition of those two.
So we need to understand that the prophetic books are really little anthologies,
anthologies of Oracle's.
They can be connected for literary rather than substantive or chronological
reasons.
You can't assume chronological sequence.
It's not like reading the historical books of Joshua through second kings.
It's very,
very different and interesting question concerns the degree to which the
prophetic books preserve the actual oracles of the profits.
Certainly there's no doubt that there has been revision and supplementation of
the prophetic books.
Not Everything in the book of Amos is from Amos himself.
Additions have been made to most of the prophetic books.
Um,
it was believed that the words of the prophets had enduring significance.
Those are received.
These words believed that they had enduring significance.
And so they were supplemented because of the conviction that they had enduring
relevance,
not despite of it,
because of it.
And some scholars believe that this accounts for the Oracle and Amos to that
prophesies the fall of Judah and he misses living in seven 50,
the latter half of the eighth century,
not in the sixth century.
He's living in the eighth century,
but he prophesized the fall of Judah.
And most people would assume that this is an addition which is made to the book
of Amos after Judas Fall.
These supplementations and additions and revisions that we will see in some of
the prophetic books.
And some of them are quite obvious.
We're not completely promiscuous.
I don't want to give you the idea that they were,
um,
because there are many instances in which a profits words are not updated,
are not modified,
even though the failure to do this leaves the prophecy a woefully out of step
with what actually came to be later.
So those kinds of inconsistencies between a profits,
words and later fact with suggests that there was a strong tendency to preserve
the words of the prophet faithfully.
So we will see both tendencies within the litter literature tendency to leave
words and tech and at the same place a tendency to supplement or to add sections
to the prophet,
the prophetic writing.
A third feature that we'll see in many of the prophetic books is what we call
the call.
And this is common to most of the profits.
It's the claim to authority as a result of having been called by God to deliver
his word.
We talked before about apostolic prophecy,
this notion of the profit as someone who is sent by God with a message,
not someone who has a consulted by a client to find out what God thinks.
The irresistibility of the call is a feature of these passages and we find it
illustrated an Amos three verses seven and eight,
after citing a series of proverbs that illustrate inexorable cause and effect,
uh,
for example,
he says,
does a trap spring up from the ground unless it is caught something.
And then the oracle continues.
A lion has roared who can but fear my lord.
God has spoken who can but prophesy.
Why does this irresistible call?
We find metaphors used,
um,
liberally throughout the prophetic writings.
And Amos describes his prophecy by means of two types of metaphors,
word and vision.
So many of the prophetic oracles will be introduced by the phrase,
the word of Yahweh came onto profit x,
the word of Yahweh.
He came sort of an image of God's speaking directly to these profits in human
language,
which is then repeated or passed on to the audience,
to the listener.
Um,
this could be understood in the literal sense.
We could take this as a metaphor behind it,
however,
is a simple idea that it is God who is communicating to the prophet and the
prophet than communicates the message to the people.
But in addition to hearing Amos and many of the other prophets also see,
so the word of the Lord comes,
but another moments,
the prophetic oracle but will be introduced by by verbs or words and connected
with seeing and vision,
hence the word seer as a designation for a profit.
Also.
Yes,
Amos is shown visions of various kinds and particularly those five visions
clumped in chapter seven,
eight,
nine.
And this is true of the profits.
Generally these visions might be visions of God's speaking or visions of God
performing some kind of action.
They might also be visions of perfectly ordinary objects or events that carry
some sort of symbolic significance.
So we have five visions in Amos in chapter seven through nine and some of them
are visions of ordinary objects,
but those objects have some special coated meaning or symbolic significance for
Israel.
And then we have visions of extraordinary things as well.
So we have a locust plague.
It's about to consume the crop.
Um,
right after the king has taken his share,
um,
his taxes of the crop.
I'm not such an extraordinary vision.
But then there's a vision of a fire that consumes the lower waters that are
pressed down below the earth and which threatens to consume even the soil,
the earth itself.
It's an extraordinary vision.
We have a vision of the plum line,
right?
The tool that's used by v builders.
There's a vision of God.
I'm destroying worshipers in the temple.
The Vision in chapter eight is an ordinary vision.
It's a vision of a basket of summer fruit.
Um,
the Hebrew word for,
for summer or summer fruit is kites.
And this is a pun because the word Kate's means end.
So the vision of kites is indicating or symbolizing the kits,
the end of Israel.
And these kinds of symbolic visions will very often,
um,
typically include puns of this,
of this type.
So,
uh,
another,
point to May just make about just the literary features of prophetic writings is
that they do contain or employ a variety of literary forms.
One commonplace form that you will see over and over again in these writings as
a form that we call the Oracle and Oracle against the nations.
This is found an aimless.
It's found also in the three large prophetic writings,
Isaiah,
Jeremiah and Ezekiel.
Amos one and two contains seven of these oracles that inveigh against the
nations.
But I must give the form a new twist.
And this is what's interesting.
Six of the seven oracles are directed against surrounding nations and they are
excoriated for they're inhumane treatment of others,
Israelite and non Israelite,
um,
during,
during wars and conflicts as punishment for their terrible war atrocities.
A divine fire is going to break out and destroy all of their palaces in four to
five places.
But then the twist comes because after these six horrific,
um,
Oracle's which condemn the nations for these brutal acts of atrocity and war,
Amos then turns to address his own people and he says,
the same divine power will consume the people of y'all way because of the
atrocities and inhumanities that they commit even in times of peace.
So the seventh,
the climactic Oracle and now senses that God's wrath will be directed at Israel.
And this is a very unwelcome,
unexpected,
um,
statement.
And you can see how he perhaps would almost draw his audience in,
you know,
by,
uh,
with these images of their enemies getting what they deserve,
only to then turn it around.
I'm having drawn them in.
I'm seduced them,
if you will,
with his words to turn around and then charge them with something even worse.
The term Israel that he uses is of course,
ambiguous.
That's one of the problems with some of the prophetic writings.
You're never completely sure whether they're prophesying against the northern
kingdom,
Israel or the house of Israel,
right?
Both kingdoms together.
Um,
the whole tribal confederation.
Some passages in Amos would suggest one,
some passages suggest the other.
Um,
the other thing that we find in Amos is an oracle against Judah,
against the southern kingdom.
This is in chapter two.
It's just two lines versus four and five.
And it's in chapter two.
And many people identify that as a later edition by an editor.
Um,
first of all,
it's written in very standard sort of Deuteronomistic language.
And also if we leave it out,
then we have a nice literary pattern.
We have six Oracle's right plus one,
we have six Oracle's against foreign nations and then we have one against
Israel.
And that pattern is a very standard literary pattern,
particularly in poetic sections of the Bible.
And the profits are written and in an elevated poetic style,
we very often have a six plus one pattern that's related to another pattern that
we also see an Amos,
which is the three plus one pattern,
right?
This is just a doubling of its six plus one.
Um,
the three plus one pattern you'll recognize,
um,
it's quite explicit at times.
Amos,
we'll say for three transgressions of Damascus for four,
I will not revoke it.
The decree of punishment,
right?
The similar kind of language is used in verse six for Gaza in verse nine for
Tire in verse 11 for Itam and verse 13 for the ammonites and so on.
So we often have this pattern.
And so the suggestion by scholars is that without that prophecy,
that prophecy concerning the fall of Judah,
which postdates Almas,
um,
you would have a nice complete six plus one pattern and this might be the sign
of a leader editor updating Thomas' prophecy so that it would look as though he
had in fact prophesied the fall of Judah.
You have other sorts of literary patterns and forms used in the prophetic works.
Some of the literary forms we see our hymns,
we see songs we see lamence,
particularly the immense are mourning for Israel as if her destruction is
already a fait accompli.
You find proverbs very often when the prophets site a proverb,
they will turn its accepted meaning on its head.
They'll take an old proverb and they'll apply it to some new situation and give
it a radically new kind of meaning to sort of shock and surprise their audience.
And I'm a s three through eight contains a lot of of proverbs,
another literary form that we'll see,
and this is an important one,
is a literary form that's called the Reeve r.
I.
V.
I have it up there or [inaudible],
which basically means a lawsuit,
specifically a covenant law suit.
Many of the prophetic books feature passages in which God basically brings a
lawsuit against the people,
charging them with breach of covenant,
breach of contract if you will.
And in these passages you have legal metaphors being used throughout,
right?
People testifying or witnessing against Israel,
can she speak in her defense and so on.
Um,
so the rebar,
the Covenant Law suit is a formal,
see here,
we'll also see it again when we get to the book of job.
So the prophetic corpus draws on the entire range of literary forms that were
available in Israelite tradition,
literary tradition.
Um,
and very often gives them a rich and,
and that's what gives the books are very rich and varied texture.
So almost is a model for us in terms of its literary features,
but it's also a model for us in terms of some of the,
the themes or the content of the book because I'm also,
we'll articulate certain themes that we will see resoundingly throughout the
prophetic literature.
There will be some variations on these themes,
but some standard themes appear here.
So we'll review those.
Now.
Um,
many scholars,
uh,
Koufman among them,
have noted that the literature of the classical prophets is most clearly and
strongly characterized by a vehement denunciation of the moral decay and social
injustice of the period.
It really doesn't matter what period.
Vehement denunciation of moral decay in social injustice is the way Katherine
phrases it almost criticizes the sins of the nation.
He's critical of everyone.
The middleclass,
the government,
the king,
the establishment,
the priests are,
they're all,
they're all plagued by a superficial kind of piety for Amos.
As for all the profits will be looking at the idea of covenant prescribes a
particular relationship with your way,
but not only with the white,
also with one's fellow human beings,
right?
The two are interlinked.
It's a sign of closeness to your way that one is concerned for Israel's poor and
needy,
right?
The two are completely intertwined.
It are.
And so a must announces the wealthy.
He denounces the powerful and the way they treat the poor.
I'm going to be reading some passages from Amos to illustrate some of these
themes.
So Amos chapter four verses one to three and listen to the dramatic rhetoric
that's used here.
This word you cows of Bashan on the hill of Symeria.
It's a capital of the northern kingdom,
Israel who defraud the poor,
who robbed the needy,
who say to your husband's brain,
and let's carouse my Lord.
God swears by His Holiness,
behold,
days are coming upon you when you will be carried off in baskets and to the last
one in fish back it's baskets and taken out of the city,
each one through a breach,
straight ahead and flung on the refuse heap.
The wonderful pun here,
because the wealthy women of Symeria are referred to as cows of Bashan.
Number Shan is an area that's very rich pasture land.
I'm in the Trans Jordan and also it's very common in Canaanite literature to
refer to the nobility and even to gods with terms like bull or ram or cow.
These were not insulting terms as they might be in our culture.
These were in fact terms that did not offend.
These were very complimentary terms.
So when he refers to the cows of Bashan,
he speaks to the women of some area as the cows of Bashan.
He's flattering them to begin with.
But the pun is quite wonderful because these women are going to end up like fat
cows as slabs of meat in the butcher's basket or in the fish basket,
which you know is flung out on the refuse heap wants it spoiled,
right?
So he takes that term,
cows have a shine and leads it to this horrendous end.
Amos,
um,
he must six verse one and verses four through seven.
This is another scaling attack on the idol life of the carefree rich who ignore
the plight of the poor.
Woe to those at ease in Zion.
Of course,
that's the capitol of the southern kingdom,
Jerusalem and those confident on the hill of Sumeria,
the northern kingdom,
you notables of the leading nation on whom the House of Israel pin their hopes,
they lie on ivory beds,
lolling on their couches,
feasting on lambs from the flock and on calves from the stalls.
They hummed snatches of song to the loo,
to the tune of the loot.
They account themselves.
Musicians like David,
they drink straight from the wine bowls and anoint themselves with the choices
oils,
but they are not concerned about the ruin of Joseph assuredly.
Right?
Soon they shall head the column of exiles.
They shall no more at festive meals.
So great image of them allying about as the head of the nation we'll be heading,
there'll be at the head of the nation as it moves into exile.
And on an archeological note,
I understand that in some area they have in fact uncovered all kinds of ivory
furniture,
um,
and ivory coverings that would then be attached to furniture.
So the image of them lolling on ivory couches in some area apparently,
uh,
makes a lot of sense.
So the moral decay,
the greed,
the indulgence of the upper classes,
this is directly responsible for the social injustice that according to the
profits outrages God,
Amos eight,
four through six,
listen to this.
You who devour the needy,
annihilating the poor of the land,
saying,
Oh,
if only the new moon were over so that we could sell grain the sabbath so that
we could offer wheat for sale using a measure that is too small and the shekel
wait,
that is too big.
Tilting and dishonest scale and selling grain refuse as grain.
We will by the poor for silver,
the needy for a pair of sandals.
The Lord Swears by the pride of Jacob.
I will never forget any of these doings again.
Notice that they are prone to extreme formulations and high flown rhetoric.
And sometimes when you strip away the rhetoric,
you see that the crimes that are being denounced are not murder and rape or
horrendous physical violence.
And these are obvious and grievous violations of social morality.
Rather many scholars have pointed out,
but I think Kauffman chief among them,
that the crimes that are denounced here are uh,
crimes that are prevalent in any society,
in any area.
The crimes that are denounced as being utterly unacceptable to God,
infuriating God to the point of destruction of the nation are the kinds of
crimes we see around us every day.
Taking bribes,
improper weights and balances,
lack of charity to the poor in difference to the plight of the debtor.
A second theme that's pointed out again by many scholars is what Calvin calls
the idea of the primacy of morality.
That is to say the idea or the doctrine that morality is not just an obligation
equal in importance to the cultic or religious obligations,
but that morality is perhaps superior to the cult.
What God requires of Israel is morality and not cultic service.
Now,
the profits are all going to have,
we're going to see many different attitudes towards the culture among the
profits.
So allow that to be,
uh,
become a more nuance statement as we go through.
Some are going to reject the cult of the entire nation.
Others will not.
So there's going to be some variation,
but certainly morality as his primary and their words could at times be very
harsh and very astonishing.
Almost five verses 21 to 24 I low.
He's speaking now as God,
right?
So God is speaking and God says,
I Loath,
I spurn your festivals.
I am not appeased by your solemn assemblies.
If you offer me burnt sacrifices or your meal sacrifices,
I will not accept them.
I will pay no heed to your gifts of fat links.
Spare me the sound of your hymns and let me not hear the music of your lutes,
but let justice well up like water righteousness,
like an unfailing stream.
This is an attack on empty piety,
on the performance of rituals,
without any meaning,
perhaps behind that performance or in accompaniment to social injustice,
right?
That the two can't happen at the same time.
And that's a theme that is sounded repeatedly throughout prophetic literature.
So for Amos and for all the profits,
injustice is sacrilege.
The ideals of the Covenant are of utmost importance,
right?
That's why they are called the standard bearers of the covenant.
Harking back to the covenant obligations.
And without,
without these,
without the ideals of the covenant,
the fulfillment of cultic ritual obligations in and of itself is a farce.
Right?
That's not to say that they would be rejected were Israel to be upholding the
covenant.
So this rejection of the cult depends of course on a caricature of cultic and
ritual performance,
right?
The profits caricature it as meaningless.
They caricature it as unconcerned with ethics or with the ideals of Justice and
righteousness.
But internal cultural conflicts often do involve the character cheering or the
ridiculing of an opponent's beliefs or practices.
But for some of the profits,
the rejection of the cult was quite radical.
That's an idea that's not yet really fully formed.
In Amos,
we're going to see again that some of the profits will reject the cult of the
nation,
not just the color of the wicked,
but,
but everyone.
Um,
even if performed properly and by righteous persons.
there will be one or two prophets who believe the cult has no inherent value or
no absolute value for God.
In some sense,
this is a view that we've already encountered in sources devoted to the cult.
Uh,
even in a source like p the priestly material prep the materials already moving
towards the idea or establishing the idea that the cult is an expression of
divine favor rather than divine need,
right?
It's,
it doesn't really have an actual value necessary for necessarily for God.
It doesn't really affect his vitality.
Um,
it's given to humans as a ritual conduit as a way to attract and maintain God's
presence within the community,
um,
or to procure atonement for four deeds or impurities that might temporarily
separate one for God.
I'm so already in the priestly source.
We have a very complicated notion of the function of the God for society and
humanity.
So the prophetic doctrine of the primacy of morality seems to be a reaction
against other views of cultic practice.
Perhaps there were popular assumptions about the automatic efficacy of the cult
and,
and its rights.
But a Kauffman has been joined by many other scholars who argue that the profits
raised morality to the level of an absolute religious value,
and they did so because they saw morality as essentially divine.
The essence of God is his moral nature.
Moral attributes are the essence of God himself.
So Koufman notes than he who requires justice and righteousness and compassion
from human beings is himself just and righteous and compassionate.
This is the prophetic view.
The moral person can metaphorically be said to share in divinity.
This is the kind of apotheosis that you find then in the prophetic writings,
not the idea of a transformation into a divine being in life or even after
death.
Um,
but the idea that one strives to be God like by imitating his moral actions.
The idea again of Hitachi o d
a third feature of the prophetic writings,
um,
this is again underscored by Kaufman but also many other scholars and that is
the profits view of history.
Their particular view of history,
their interpretation of the catastrophic events of seven 22 and five 86.
It's an interpretation that centers on their elevation of morality because the
profits insisted that morality was a decisive,
if not the decisive factor in the nation's history,
right?
Israel's acceptance of God's covenant placed certain religious and moral demands
on her.
Now in the Deuteronomistic view that we've talked about,
one,
sin is singled out as being historically decisive for the nation.
Other sins are punished,
absolutely,
but only one is singled out as being historically decisive for the nation.
And that's the sin of idolatry,
particularly the idolatry of the royal house.
So the Deuteronomistic historian presents the tragic history of the two kingdoms
as essentially a sequence of idolatrous aberrations,
which were followed by punishment.
And this the psycho continued into continued until finally there had to be
complete destruction.
While it's certainly true that moral sins and other religious sins in his or
were punishable,
and in the Deuteronomy this view,
it's really only the worship of other gods that brings about national collapse
national exile.
And that view is exemplified in second kings chapter 17 which I read to you.
It doesn't mention moral sins as leading to the collapse of the state.
It harps on idolatry.
Idolatry was what provoked God to drive the nation into exile.
The view of the classical profits is a little different.
Israel's history is determined by moral factors,
not just religious factor.
So the nation is punished,
not only fire a dollar tree,
but for moral failings.
And of course the two are to a large degree intertwined,
but the emphasis on the moral is striking in the profits.
And it may not be so startling to hear that God would doom a generation or
domination for,
uh,
for grave moral sins like murder and violence.
This is something we've already seen,
right?
And the generation of the flood,
uh,
the cities of Sodom and Gomorrah,
they were destroyed for grievous violations of morality,
murder,
um,
violence and so on.
The profits,
however,
are claiming that the nation is doomed because of commonplace wrongs,
because of bribe taking,
because of false scales and false weights that are being used in the
marketplace.
These are the crimes for which destruction of the nation and exile will take
place.
Amos two,
verses six through eight,
thus said the Lord for three transgressions of Israel for four,
I will not revoke the decree of destruction because they have sold for silver.
Those whose causes just write,
taking bribes in,
in a courtroom setting and the needy for a pair of sandals.
Uh,
you who trample the heads of the poor into the dust of the ground and make the
humble walk a twisted course.
So this is the first difference really between the Deuteronomistic
interpretation of the nation's history and the destruction of Israel and the
prophetic interpretation for the profits.
The national catastrophes are just punishment for sin,
but not just the sin of idolatry for all sins,
no matter how petty,
no matter how venial because all sins violate the terms of the Covenant Code
which has given especially to Israel.
Right.
And the terms of the covenant being vassals to the sovereign yeah way means
treating co vassals in a particular way and it is breach of Covenant Covenant
not to do that.
And again,
how much the profits were harking back to an older tradition to ancient
traditions about Israel and its covenant relationship,
um,
traditions according to which Israel's redemption and election entailed moral
obligations,
how much they were,
the ones to actually generate and argue for.
This idea again,
is hotly debated by scholars.
It's not an issue that we need to decide.
But I would note that the primacy of morality in Israel,
religion certainly dates back at least to the times of the earliest profits.
Amos in the eighth century for example,
and may indeed have had antecedents,
it's certainly didn't just arrive,
arise in the exile as some scholars would have us believe.
It's certainly was not the invention of the Deuteronomistic historian.
It's alive and well in some of these very early profits.
I'm going to turn now to the second difference between the Deuteronomistic and
the prophetic interpretation of Israel's history.
And that is that the profits coupled their message of,
of tragedy and doom with a message of hope and consolation.
And this is something that just simply doesn't come within the purview of the
Deuteronomistic historians writing
first,
let me say a little bit about the message of doom and then,
um,
the message of hope and consolation.
One of the things that's so interesting in the classical prophets is that they
give a new content to older Israelite ideas about the end of days or what we
call eschatology,
eschatology and account of the Eschaton eschaton meaning the end.
So an eschatology is and account of the end,
the prophets warned that unless they changed the people,
we're going to suffer the punishment that was do them.
And in fact the people were very foolish to be eagerly awaiting,
are eagerly expecting what was popularly known as the day of Yom Kippur,
the day of the Lord.
I said the prophets referred to the day of Yahweh's as if it were a popular
conception out there in the general culture.
Um,
it was a popular idea at the time that on some future occasion God would
dramatically intervene and world affairs and he would do so on Israel's behalf.
He would lead Israel in victory over her enemies.
They would be punished.
Israel will be restored to her full and former glory.
And that day,
the day of the Lord or the day of [inaudible] in the popular mind was going to
be a marvelous day,
a day of victory for Israel,
triumph for Israel,
and the day of vengeance on her enemies.
Amos five verses 18 and 29 talks about the people as desirous of the day of
[inaudible].
They're very confident that this is going to be a day of light,
day of blessing,
a day of victory.
He says,
but the profits,
I must among them tell a different story according to tell them,
if there is no change,
then this day of y'all way is not going to be some glorious thing that the
people should be eagerly awaiting.
It's not going to be a day of triumph for Israel.
It will not be a day of vengeance on her enemies.
It's going to be a dark day of destruction.
It's going to be a day of doom when God will finally call his own people to
account.
So this is another instance of the way in which the the profits tried to
radically surprise their audience by taking an older concept and and reversing
its meaning,
changing it's meaning.
And here they've transformed the popular image of the day.
If your way from one of national triumph to one of national judgment,
Amos five verses 18 through 20 I you who wish for the day of Yahweh's,
why should you want the day of the Lord?
It shall be darkness,
not light.
As if a man should run from align and be attacked by a bear,
or if he got endorsed,
should lean his hand on the wall and be bitten by a snake,
there's going to be no place to hide.
In other words,
surely the day of the Lord shall not be light,
but darkness,
blackness night without a glimmer or chapter eight verses nine through 12 and in
that day declares my Lord God,
I will make the sun set at noon.
I will darken the earth on a sunny day and I will turn your festivals into
mourning and all your songs and to dirge is I will put sackcloth on all loins
and Tantra is on every head.
Morning rights.
I will make it mourn as for an only child,
all of it as on a bitter day.
So again,
at the heart of this idea that the day of you always being transformed me to
this day of judgement is the old idea that God is the god of history,
right?
God can control the destiny of nations.
He can control the actions of nations.
It's not a new idea,
but in the past,
or not so much in the past,
I suppose that would have been present to the profits.
The profits were reacting against a notion that God's involvement with other
nations was always undertaken on Israel's behalf.
This is the idea they seem to be battling.
In other words,
they're battling the idea or the assumption that God controlled other nations by
exercising judgment on them and punishing them and subjecting them to Israel,
and the profits are challenging this idea and they're making a very shocking of
what would have been hurt as a shocking and extraordinary claim.
God is of course,
yes,
the god of history of all history.
He is concerned with all,
not only Israel,
but his involvement with other nations doesn't extend merely to their
subjugation if need be or rather if Israel deserves,
then God will raise up another nation against her.
So the final chapter,
nameless begins by proclaiming this idea of utter destruction.
I will slay them all God says,
and not one of them shall survive wherever they hide under the Earth,
in the heavens,
at the bottom of the sea.
Gods going to haul them out and he's going to slay them.
And what about the covenant?
Isn't it a,
a guarantee of privilege or safety?
Um,
again,
for Amos,
its primary function is to bind the nation.
Um,
in a code of conduct and violations of that code,
we're going to be severely punished.
So in chapter nine,
verses seven to eight,
Amos uh,
makes the startling claim that in God's eyes,
Israel,
it's really no different from the rest of the nations.
He elevated her.
He can also lower her to me.
Oh,
Israelites,
you are just like the Ethiopians.
True.
I brought Israel up from the land of Egypt,
but also the Philistines from cuff door and the Armenians from care before.
Behold the Lord God has his eye upon the sinful kingdom and I will wipe it off.
The face of the earth is a harsh,
harsh words.
And you also have to remember that almost was living in a time of relative peace
and prosperity.
Not Seven 50.
Um,
national competence is riding high.
Uh,
the people of Israel were pretty convinced that God was with them.
They weren't in Randy real imminent or obvious danger and almost was convinced
that despite this external appearance of health,
uh,
the nation was disease,
they were guilty of social crimes and unfaithfulness to their covenantal
obligations.
And so he says they're headed down this path of destruction.
And perhaps because of the optimism of the time,
Amos had to emphasize this message of doom because his,
his book is a pretty depressing a book.
Um,
later prophets who are speaking in a different,
uh,
historical setting and a more desperate historical setting will often speak
words of much more comfort and,
and,
um,
uh,
and hope.
But Amos doesn't do this.
He does indicate that his purpose is the reformation or the reorientation of the
nation.
He wants to awaken Israel to the fact that change is needed.
Amos five,
verses 14 and 15,
seek good and not evil that you may live.
And that the Lord the God of hosts make truly be with you.
As you think right now,
you think he's with you.
He's not change,
right?
So that he will truly be with you,
hate,
evil and love good and establish justice in the gate.
Perhaps the Lord,
the God of hosts will be gracious to the remnant of Joseph.
There perhaps is important and it's very indicative of Amos's fatalism.
This is very much a fatalistic book.
The overriding theme of Imus's message is that punishment is inevitable.
It's pretty much inevitable.
And this is one of the reasons that most scholars believe that the final verses
of the book,
um,
versus my halfway through eight down to 15 are a later edition by an editor.
Um,
it's an epilogue and it was likely added in order to relieve the gloom and the
pessimism and the fatalism of the profits message because in these verses almost
does an almost complete about face.
Um,
you've just,
we've just finished nine of the first half of verse eight in Chapter Nine.
So nine,
8:00 AM you have this oracle of complete and devastating judgment.
Behold the Lord God has his eye upon the sinful kingdom.
I will wipe it off the face of the earth.
But then the second half of the verse and the beginning of this epilogue that's
been added immediately dilutes this,
but I will not wholly wipe out the house of Jacob,
declares the Lord.
It seems that an editor editor has qualified this last oracle of doom as what
was desired to qualify this last article of doom and the editor continues for.
I will give the order and shakes the house of Israel through all the nations as
one shakes sand in a sieve and not a pebble falls to the ground.
All the centers of my people shall perish by the sword who boast never shall the
evil overtake us or come near us.
And in that day I will set up again the fallen booth of David.
I will mend its breaches and set up its ruins,
a new and I will build it from as in the days of old,
a time is coming,
declares the Lord.
When the mountains shall drip wine and all the hills shall wave with grain and I
will restore my people Israel,
they will rebuild ruined cities and inhabit them and they shall till gardens and
eat their fruits and I will plant them upon their soil.
Nevermore to be approached Rupp rooted from the soil.
I have given them,
said the Lord your God.
In other words,
according to this epilogue,
God's punishment of Israel isn't the end of the story.
It's one step in a process and the affliction and the punishment serve a
purpose.
It's to purge the dross to chase in Israel.
They're going to be put through a sieve.
Only the sinner's will really parish.
I'm a remnant.
Presumably a righteous remnant will be permitted to survive and in due time that
remnant will be restored.
Um,
to summarize,
Amos and I,
hopefully,
hopefully this'll give us,
send some foothold as we move into other prophetic books.
We need to understand that the book of Amos is a set of Oracle's by a prophet
addressing a concrete situation in the northern kingdom.
It's been subject to some additions that reflect the perspective of a later
editor.
Um,
Amos's message was that sin would be punished by God and it would be punished on
a national level,
right?
The Nation would fall when the northern kingdom fell.
It was understood to be a fulfillment of Amos's words.
The Assyrians were the instruments of God's just punishment.
So his words were preserved in Judah after Judah fell,
presumably a later editor editor added a few key passages to reflect this later
reality.
Most significantly,
the Oracle against Judah in chapter two verse four five and the Epilogue in
chapter nine verse eight,
beat to 15,
which explicitly seem to refer to the fall of,
of the southern kingdom,
right?
The,
uh,
every first for a future day when the fallen booth of David will be raised,
that reflects a knowledge of the end of Judah and the end of the Davidic
kingship.
And the phrase on that day,
which is used as a phrase that often signals what we feel is an editorial
insertion in a prophetic book.
It's pointing forward to some vague future time of restoration.
Okay.
On Monday,
we are going to be moving on to Hosea and Isaiah.